Now that we've discussed a smallpox
and its impact on the human body,
it's symptomatology this morning I want
to concentrate instead on the impact,
uh,
on history and I want to concentrate
on three aspects in particular.
The first part would be to
look at its impact in Europe.
The second and much more dramatic story
is the impact that you're reading about
in Elizabeth Fenn,
which is what happened with smallpox in
the new world and also in Australia and
New Zealand.
The third task for the morning is to
come to the a very different story,
which is smallpox and the development
of a public health strategy.
In this case, the development
of the strategy of vaccine.
So those are the three topics I
like to deal with this morning.
And so let's begin with the
impact of smallpox in Europe.
Smallpox, uh, has a legend about it.
The legend,
it goes like this,
that it was brought back to Europe from
the Middle East by returning crusaders
in the 11th and 12th centuries.
As you know,
the Crusades lasted from 10 95 to 1291.
And those are said to be this time
of armies in movement and transit,
uh,
to be the means of transmitting small pox,
back to western Europe.
There is no reason for us to accept
the truth of that legend as accurate.
But there is something
interesting about it. First, uh,
there's some support,
uh,
which is that Saint Nikkei's who was
a crusader of the order of Saint John,
he had an unhappy experience
in the Middle East.
He was captured and beheaded, but, uh,
thereafter he became the patron
saint of smallpox suffers
a cult of St Nikkei's.
Uh,
he's from rims is,
uh,
in particular spread across the continent
and churches were devoted to him.
And there were representations
of this saint in stain glass,
windows in effigies and statues like this.
This is Saint Nick case at Reims
Cathedral of Saint Nick case.
And an angel.
There isn't any hard evidence that small
parks did return with the Crusaders.
Um,
although we all know that warfare is a
time that favors the spread of infectious
diseases.
And it's probably true that smallpox
had already been present in Europe for
centuries.
But there's something about this date,
which is that what it tells us is
not when smallpox actually began,
but when it first began
to attract attention
in any case.
Okay.
We know too that smallpox,
although it was present in
Europe during the Crusades,
the conditions at that time led to
it's beginning to have a more important
impact that reached its high point in the
late 17th and then throughout the 18th
century.
Okay.
And that had to do with preconditions
that enabled it to flourish,
preconditions associated
with industrial development,
the commercialization of agriculture
and rapid unplanned urbanization.
And this 18th century,
smallpox had clearly replaced plague
as the greatest and most filled feared
killer of its time.
No. And its history, the
fact that a sufferer,
and we mentioned this last time,
who recovered,
possessed a robust lifelong immunity
to this disease was important.
No one was naturally
infected twice with smallpox.
So a typical pattern emerged
in the cities of Europe.
And that was that smallpox became an
ever present disease that most people who
survived childhood had suffered.
The adult population,
therefore possessed what we might call
an extensive herd immunity to smallpox as
a disease.
So it became an endemic
disease of childhood,
but at intervals,
perhaps every generation or so,
smallpox would erupt as a major
epidemic among the general population.
Okay.
A couple of factors came into
play to reinforce this pattern.
Obviously not every child
contracted the disease,
and so over time there'd be a slow
accumulation of non-immune susceptible
adults.
Yeah.
Who could fall ill of the,
it was also true that European cities in
the early modern era where so unhealthy
that they sustained or
expanded their population,
not by growth from within,
but by a constant influx of people from
without peasants driven off the land,
perhaps by hunger or warfare
or the search for work,
failed harvests,
and these newcomers in large numbers
to use a contemporary medical jargon or
immunologically naive that is,
they were susceptible and added to the
pool of susceptibles in urban centers.
So in every generation,
we're so urban centers whose children
had already suffered some smallpox as an
endemic child to a disease,
suffered major epidemics
among not only children,
but young adults,
adolescents, and older people.
So smallpox is an example of a disease.
And we'll see malaria as another one
for which there is no simple distinction
between endemic and epidemic.
Smallpox was both endemic year
in and year out in Europe,
and it was also epidemic
sporadically every generation or so.
It thrived in crowded urban environments
with throngs of people and poorly
vented houses and workshops.
Now in the 18th century
statistics or elusive.
But smallpox is commonly thought,
and this is just a guesstimate to have
caused perhaps a 10th of all deaths in
the century in Europe and a third of all
deaths among children under 10 years of
age.
Half the population of the continent
is estimated to have been scarred or
disfigured by this disease.
And smallpox was also the leading
cause of blindness across Europe.
Perhaps half a million. This
is again, only a guesstimate.
People died annually from this disease.
In other words,
it was the equivalent of the largest
city in Europe at the time in the 18th
century was Naples with
half a million people.
It was as if a city of that size
disappeared from this single disease every
year.
The 19th century English poet and
historian Thomas Babington Macaulay road,
this about smallpox,
the havoc of plague had
been formed more rapid,
but the plague has visited our shores
only once or twice in living memory.
But smallpox was always there filling
the church yards with corpses,
torn mentoring with constant fear,
all limited,
not yet stricken and leaving on
those whose lives it's spared,
the hideous traces of its power,
turning the baby into a changeling at
which the mother shuttered and making the
eyes and cheeks of the patrol maiden
objects of horror to her lover.
Okay,
so two of the most famous descriptions
of smallpox in the century were those
that described it as the speckled
monster and the most terrible of all the
ministers of death.
Furthermore,
like blegh though smallpox was an
airborne disease unlike plague,
but like influenza,
and it was an affliction that was
universal and had no predilection for any
subset of the population such as the poor.
It wasn't really a nonsense,
a social disease.
Even royal families were scourged,
buy small parks.
And the 17th and 18th centuries famous
sufferers and victims included King
Louis,
the 14th and Louis,
the 15th of Friends,
William the second of orange,
Peter, the second of Russia, the
Holy Roman Emperor Joseph, the first
in England,
smallpox was even directly
responsible for a dynastic change.
It extinguished the House of Stuart,
the last Stuart heirs to the throne all
died of smallpox between the death of
Queen Mary in 1694 and the death of
11 year old Prince William also from
smallpox in 1700 so this was a clear
case in which a disease produced a
constitutional crisis and led to the
act of settlement of 1701 that prevented
another Catholic from being crowned
and brought in the house of Hanover.
So small pox had a major
impact in western Europe,
but it's impact is not as simple
repetition of the story of plague.
Although it was dreaded.
Smallpox did not give rise in Europe
to mass hysteria scapegoating and the
religious frenzy and their reasons
for that can surmise unlike plague.
Small pox was not a sudden outside
invader that took society by surprise,
nor did it maximize its fury by targeting
young adults and the middle aged who
were the mainstays of families.
End of the economy.
Smallpox was an endemic
disease that was ever present.
And so it was considered almost normal,
especially because it targeted
infants and children as a rule.
Although as I've said,
it did lead sporadically
to broader epidemics.
So as a result,
everyone had some experience with small
polyps and half the people you might
meet on the street in a city of western
Europe would be pockmarked with as a
reminder of its passage
so familiar with smallpox,
that it bred a kind of fatalism,
the belief that it was
inevitable in people's lives.
And this attitude was so pervasive that
it wasn't uncommon even for parents to
expose healthy children intentionally to
mild cases and the hope that they could
protect them from something
much more catastrophic.
We could look at this attitude,
buy or appreciated by thinking
about European literature,
particularly British literature,
let's say in the 18th century.
Let's think for example of Henry
fieldings novel, Tom Jones,
and not when it was useful
to have a change in plot.
All the author had to do was to introduce
the idea of smallpox because no one
would question that that was appropriate
or considered that this was a clumsy or
artificial advice.
Artifice.
Everyone expected smallpox,
and in fieldings novel Joseph Andrews,
we find that there's a heroine who
is pockmarked or consider factories.
The adventures of Henry Esmond said in
the 18th century were smallpox drives the
plot.
Smallpox quite simply was just there
and it came to seem for many people a
terrible but everyday part
of the human condition.
So smallpox didn't cause great European
cities like London to empty of their
population.
When people took to the road in flight
as plague did in the 17th century.
And as we shall see that cholera was to
do again in the 19th century and there
an urge to seek scape goods for what
seemed almost natural or normal event.
But this is a generalization and there
are reports of some who lost their nerve
at the approach of smallpox
and sought refuge in flight.
Let's return to our novel Henry Esmond.
There's a heroine lady Castlewood who
contract smallpox as an adult in a country
village.
Her husband,
and this was surprising because we
were told early on that he was an
extraordinarily brave soldier,
but he was a man who couldn't bear to
face a disease that he couldn't fight and
threatened him not only with death,
but this seemed to matter perhaps
more to him than death itself.
He thought he was extremely handsome and
he was afraid that he would be maimed
if he survived.
So unwilling to put his fair complexion
and is even fair hair at risk.
Lord Castlewood took to his heels
and he deserted his household for the
duration,
but he wasn't part of a mass exodus.
Although factory does have Henry
Esmond the hero of the story,
uh, tell us himself that
smallpox was, in his words,
the most dreadful scourge of the world.
We also know that as
a result of four deal,
lady Castlewood lost her beauty and
then her gallon husband on his return no
longer loved her as he
wants did as readers.
Then we know that one of the effects with
smallpox was that it had a big impact
on the marriage market,
it disfigured people and made them less
likely to succeed in the sweepstakes.
We learned that Kelly de Castlewood,
according to the author,
her beauty was very much
injured by the small pox.
When the marks of the
disease cleared away,
the delicacy of her color
and complexion was all gone.
Her eyes had lost their brilliancy.
Her hair fell and her face looked old.
It was as if a course hand to rubbed
off the delicate tense of that sweet
picture and brought to it a dread color.
It also,
it must be owned.
Her ladies ships nose was greatly
swollen and red in any case.
As you can imagine,
having scars on pockmarks was also a
source of great psychological distress and
unhappiness.
And this too was part of the plot
of Thackeray's novel as it unfolds.
And part of what we should remember as
the impact of smallpox on the terrible
18th century,
but that was smallpox in Europe,
a major source of anxiety,
a major impact on population,
uh,
source of the cult of the St and e case.
Uh,
a major factor in demography,
but there's a more dramatic story that
we need to come to as we crossed the
waters and turns the new world or
also Australia and New Zealand.
This is the story of what happened when
the disease was suddenly introduced to
populations and part of the
world where it was a new invader.
Work arrived from outside,
had never been an endemic infection and
therefore against which the native or
aboriginal population
had no immunity at all,
then it produced real catastrophes.
Events describe as virgin soil epidemics.
These were catastrophes that accompanied
European expansion to the new world,
Australia,
New Zealand,
and they're smallpox and another
child to disease that accompanied it.
Measles had a transformative importance
in clearing the lend and promoting
settlement by Europeans
with their robust immunity.
The impact of smallpox and measles.
Measles was greater than that of gunpowder
in the new world.
You'll be reading about this in detail
in that wonderful book by Elizabeth Fenn,
Pox Americana,
and you might want to be reminded of
the simple fact that the author was
actually a Yalie and that the book that
you're reading began life here as a phd
dissertation.
In any case though,
I want to have the division
of labor between the lectures
and the reading and so
I won't repeat the story that phen tells,
so movingly and so well,
but there were a few points that I would
like to highlight as specific examples
and a couple of general points.
And first the general idea we should
remember is not of something sometimes
referred to as the Colombian exchange.
That is to say that the European and
counter with the new world brought about
the large scale exchange from one side
of the Atlantic to the other and in the
reverse direction of fauna and flora.
Certainly as you know,
Europeans brought back the potato maze
and Quinine for as examples from the
Americas and there's been a debate as to
whether this also involved in microbial
component and there are those who
speculate that Columbus and his sailors
brought back the disease syphilis
as well from the new world.
We'll be returning to that argument later
in the semester when we come to talk
about syphilis as a disease.
What's beyond out though is that there
was also a terrible movement of microbes
in the other direction as Europeans
unintentionally introduced smallpox and
measles to the Americas.
Let's illustrate with a specific
example of the Colombian exchange.
The exchange phen tells us about by
looking at this much travailed island of
Hispaniola,
the mountainous Caribbean island where
Columbus landed in the 1490s he spun
Yola. That is what is modern
Haiti and the Dominican Republic.
And as we know from today's news,
Haiti has a long history of
natural and manmade catastrophes.
And the arrival of
Columbus was certainly one
the aboriginal inhabitants,
a tribe known as the hour wax,
our estimated or guesstimated to have
numbered something like a million people
in 1492
Columbus described Hispaniola
as almost an earthly paradise,
a place of great natural beauty.
And you reported that the Roi box,
we're a welcoming and non war like
people who greeted the Spanish warmly and
showed them great kindness.
But unfortunately for them the
kindness wasn't reciprocal.
The Spaniards were interested in profit
and international power politics and he
spun Yolo was strategically located.
It also possessed fertile soil,
a favorable climate and
land at the Spanish crown,
coveted for cultivation.
So European interest
was based on commerce,
profit and international
power considerations.
The Spaniards militarily dispossessed
the wraps of their lend and intended to
reduce them to slavery first
in minds and then on the land.
They were assisted in the process
up to a point by two great assets,
gunpowder and disease.
Yeah.
And as you know from hating fen,
the aboriginal population of the Americas
lacked immunity to European diseases
like smallpox and measles.
Okay.
There's no evidence that there was a
plot of genocide or bio terror in the
intentional use of disease as a means
to clear the land and resettled.
What happened was spontaneous
and not intentional,
but the encounter between Europeans and
the indigenous peoples of Hispaniola
resulted in an extraordinary
and terrifying die off
between 1492 and 1520 the
native population was reduced
from a million people to
15,000 disease thoroughly
cleared.
He Spun Yola for European colonization
virtually without resistance.
On the other hand,
small pumps forded the Spanish
intention and Hispaniola to enslave the
aboriginals.
They simply died off at two extraordinary,
you're raped at therefore led the
Spaniards out of necessity to turn to a
different source of labor
for Mines and plantations.
And since Africans and Europeans shared
disease reservoirs that were partially
overlapping,
there are people resistant to many of
the sane epidemic diseases that had
destroyed the native Americans.
So disease was a major factor in the
establishment of the African slave trade
and the development of new world slavery.
The Spaniards hardly delayed 1517 mark,
the beginning of the
importation of African slaves
to Hispaniola son Domingo by
1789 received into which supports every
year some 1,600 ships employing 24,000
shalers and it accounted for 11 million
pounds of the French total of 17 million
pounds of EPC sports.
It's trade was the foundation
of the wealth of port cities.
Like not we're doe and
more say it's cotton.
A basis for the French
textile mills and Norman date.
And the growth was exponential between
1783 in 1789 production doubled.
And with it,
the importation of slaves,
10,000 a year in 1764 15,017 71 27,017
86 40,017 87 the leading port of Sun
Domingo,
the prosperous city of look,
Cop Fall Swat had 20,000 people and
was called the Paris of the West.
So the Colombian exchange played a major
role in the history of Hispaniola and
that was written large in
the new world as a whole.
A similar story could be told about Aaron
Non Cortez and his fellow conquistador
Francisco Pizarro with regard to the Aztec
Empire of Mexico and the Incan Empire
of Peru,
which were destroyed not only by
gunpowder but also by smallpox.
That destroyed agriculture,
lead to famine,
destroyed the aboriginal military
capacity to resist and had were told a
tremendous psychological impact because
they're gods seemed not to protect them
and so there was a wave of conversion to
the European God who seemed to protect
his own people.
Now you also know from reasoning Elizabeth
Fenn that although this process was
primarily unintentional,
there were moments within it,
within the larger catastrophe
of occasional act of
intentional genocide and one
was by a Lord Jeffrey Amherst,
whom we're portraying here,
who intentionally gave native
Americans infected blankets.
I thought I perhaps tell you a little
anecdote that I won't vouch for
historically.
I know of it from a oral history,
from friends I had at the
time who attended Amherst
college and told me about a
demonstration that I think took place
in 1968 but that was that the plates
you've just seen, Lord
Jeffrey, who actually,
uh,
intentionally aimed at the die off of
aboriginal populations and intentionally
gave native Americans,
uh,
blankets infected with smallpox scabs.
Well,
the plates at Amherst College at in the
1960s look like this and they show a
surge.
Jeffery scourging Indian population
with a whip on horseback.
And so in 1968,
uh,
learning about the experience of genocide,
there was a demonstration when the
students of Amherst college stood up and
smashed all the plates and the
dining hall. Um, in any case,
that was also the case that this sort
of tremendous dial off that fat affected
the Americas,
cleared the land for European
settlement was repeated.
Again,
not intentionally,
but with regard in Australia
to the aboriginals and in
New Zealand with regards
to the mayoress.
But you have that story told vividly on,
on a large canvas by Elizabeth fans,
pox Americana.
So I'll leave you to read about that and
I'd like to turn now to our third point
of the morning,
which was the development,
the importance of smallpox for
an entirely different reason.
And that is the development of a new
and major public health strategy.
The strategy of inoculation initially,
and that becomes more definitively
the strategy of vaccination.
Okay,
well let's begin with inoculation.
Oh,
what is inoculation?
It was an empirical practice,
we might call it a folk art and it was
developed in various parts of the world
as a result of two very
simple observations.
Okay.
The first was that small
pox was clearly contagious.
The second was that those
who had recovered from the
disease and it was easy to
know who had suffered from it because
there were scarred and pockmarked or also
there were often blind.
And it was a simple observation that
they never caught smallpox a second time.
Okay.
So the idea developed that it might be
a wise measure to induce a mild case of
small pox artificially to protect a
person or especially a child from the risk
of acquiring a naturally occurring but
severe and life threatening or maiming
case.
Okay.
And the practice that resulted
was called variously inoculation,
very elation or in a gardening
metaphor and grafting.
There were variations,
but then major technique was it liquid
material from a small pox postural.
You saw those last time.
Okay.
Of a patient selected for having a very
mild was allowed to soak into a thread.
The thread was then inserted into a
superficial cup made with the Lancet,
this sharp instrument that you've seen
pictures of and an earlier lecture into
the arm of the person to be protected
and fastened there for 24 hours.
12 days later,
the subject usually fell
ill with small punks,
hopefully suffered from a
mild case for about a month.
Convalesced for a further month and
then remained immune for a lifetime.
Hopefully not park mark marked or blinded.
Now.
This practice of inoculation was common
in places like Turkey in the 18th
century but not in western Europe.
A major role in bringing this practice
to Britain and western Europe was played
by this lady, the wife of the
British ambassador to Turkey,
Lord and Lady Mary Montagu who lived
from 1689 to 1762 and she was preoccupied
with small parks in part because your
own beauty had been compromised by a
severe attack of the disease and she
elected to protect her own children by
having them inoculated by the
practice I've just described.
While they were in Constantinople,
she returned to England
in 1721 and launched a one
person or one lady mission to
convince society to introduce
the practice of inoculation.
She devoted herself to propagandizing
British society in the practice.
She was able to convince the Princess of
Wales who had her daughter's inoculated
and the practice spread rapidly.
Now,
this was the first major public health
advance in dealing with small punks,
and as I tried to suggest last time,
I would argue that it had a role
note that I'm saying only a role,
not the role as part of the background
for the coming of the enlightenment.
Indeed leading fuel of sof became ardent
advocates of inoculation people in
France like Voltaire and Charles Dilla
Condamine or on this side of the water.
People in light also describe as Philo's
off like Benjamin Franklin and Thomas
Jefferson.
Inoculation appropriately
gain most favor in England,
the epicenter perhaps
of smallpox in Europe,
but it gradually spread also
to France, Holland, Germany,
Sweden in Russia,
the procedure was introduced by Catherine
the great who imported an English
physician to inoculate her in 1768 after
which the nobility rapidly adopted the
practice.
The cresting wave then of the smallpox
epidemic in the 18th century in Europe
was met by the first practical
measure of public health against it.
Well,
why did inoculation work?
At least to the extent that it did,
and I would say that inoculation
was a partial success.
Biological processes were at work
that are still poorly understood,
but there are a couple of relevant
factors that we could note.
One was not as a matter of practice,
this procedure took infected
material only from very mild cases.
That was this selection then of
cases was one reason behind it.
Success,
the infective matter also was made to
enter the body through the skin in a way
that doesn't happen in nature and for
reasons that aren't understood attenuates
the variance of the virus.
So the portal of entry into the body
also seems to have made a difference.
And lastly,
for all at one knows,
those who were inoculated were also
selected and you were only chosen for
inoculation if you are healthy and robust.
There were, however, problems.
Inoculation was also a
partially flawed procedure.
All too often,
despite all precautions,
it failed to produce the
desired mild infection,
but led and said to
severe illness and death,
and invariably it caused a month
or two of immense suffering.
It was also costly since
physicians insisted on a
lengthy period of preparation
when they were performing the procedure,
wanting to ensure that those they
inoculated, we're an excellent health.
They selected patients carefully and
then isolated them for a month before the
procedure during which
they regulated their diet,
their fresh air there exercise,
and this was obviously
an expensive process,
so inoculation was simply
not accessible to the poor.
Another factor was that inoculation
could run the risk because it introduced
actual smallpox cases and therefore it
ran the risk of setting off an epidemic
unintentionally that those who contracted
the disease would then spread it to
others around them.
And to prevent that smallpox inoculation
hospitals such as one in London that
opened in 1746 we're set up to care for
the patients who had been inoculated and
to quarantine them so that they
were no longer a risk to others.
But nevertheless,
there was a spirit to debate over the
whole issue of rather on balance and
knock. Culation saved many
more lives than it killed.
Well, that brings us to this figure,
a decisive figure in the history
of medicine and public health.
And that is Edward Jenner.
It was in the context of this small pox
catastrophe of the 18th century and of
disappointments and anxieties surrounding
inoculation that we see a decisive
discovery in the history of medicine
and public health associated with this
English country doctor.
To understand what happened,
we need to remember
what we said last time.
And that is that there were three species
of the genus of worth of pox viruses,
Vario, Olin Major, Vario,
alon minor, and cow pox.
The first two are exclusively
infectious to human beings,
but the third mainly affects council.
But the point is that
under the right conditions,
cow pox can be transmitted to humans
among whom it induces a mild illness.
But it provides,
and this was the crucial point,
a robust crossover immunity
to vary all a major
now in Britain that people thought
most likely to contract cow pox.
We're Noke mates and Jenner,
and this is why I stress that
he was a country doctor. Uh,
this is his home in Barkley
in Gloucester shirt.
I'm in the west of England.
He made an observation that could only
have been made by a doctor with a rural
practice in a dairy county at a
time of prevalence of smallpox.
And this observation was that milkmaids
never seem to come down with a small
pumps,
gender like others.
She wasn't the first to
make this observation,
but he took it to heart and attempted
the next step of an experimentation.
A crucial experiment occurred in 1796.
The milkmaid,
Sarah Nelms contracted cow pox.
And this is me. Uh,
we'll see the experiment.
Edward Jenner,
um,
chuck the infective
material from Sarah Nelms.
Okay.
And vaccinated.
The eight year old son of
his gardener on his property
in 1796 and then after a period of time,
had a challenge in vacuum and
vaccination with live smallpox virus.
Okay.
And hopefully the experiment
was a great success.
And Edward Phipps demonstrated that he
was immune by this procedure to small
pox.
And so soon thereafter,
Edward Jenner,
a whatever one thinks by modern terms
of the medical ethics of that particular
experiment.
In 1798 Edward Jenner wrote one
of the most influential pieces,
works in the history of medicine inquiry
into the causes and effects of the
Vario low voc scene.
I,
his genius was not just to devise the
experiment that was scientifically flawed,
perhaps in the sense that he extrapolated
from a very small vape database,
but in any case,
the point is that he recognized the
significance of what he discovered.
He thought that he saw immediately the
possibility of eradicating smallpox from
the planet,
an idea who is important.
The British parliament recognized soon
afterwards when it declared vaccination.
The greatest discovery I'm quoting in
the history of medicine general wrote in
1801 that he longed for the
annihilation of the smallpox,
the most dreadful scourge
of the human race.
That must be the final
result of this practice.
So gender had the genius to see the full
implication of his discovery and then
he devoted the remainder of his life,
single mindedly to the cause of
promoting this revolutionary method,
not only in Britain,
but also globally was also
the first example of a new
and highly effective style
of public health by vaccination.
A method that's proved its effectiveness
certainly with regard to smallpox,
but you could also mention polio,
tetanus, rabies, influenza,
diptheria,
shingles and a host of other diseases
and gender soon made influential converts
who establish vaccination as a
major instrument of public health.
Napoleon in France,
Pope Pius the seventh in Rome,
Benjamin Waterhouse and Thomas
Jefferson on these shores.
Generous method then was a means to
combat smallpox and unlike inoculation
vaccination didn't introduce an infection
of smallpox itself and therefore had
no risk of setting off
an unintended epidemic.
It also had a low risk of
serious complications for
the individual patient and
no risk at all for the community.
But there were problems with generous
method and it was to require a series of
subsequent improvements to make
vaccination of fully successful procedure.
The problems involves such things as
he required at the time and arm to arm
method and this entailed the risk of
spreading other diseases in particular
syphilis while trying
to present small pumps.
There were also failed vaccinations that
led to complications and gender made an
a crucial mistake.
He made it an article of dogmatic faith
that the community derive from smallpox
vaccination artificially was lifelong,
just like the natural immunity that was
acquired and he steadfastly refused to
consider evidence that ran counter to
his dog ma and fact artificial immunity
wears off.
It's now known after a period
that's not quite understood,
but 10 1520 years and requires to
still be valid revaccinated option.
This blindness on generous part discredit
vatted vaccination in some quarters
and was one factor.
These various limitations.
Then for one of the most powerful mass
movements of the 19th century and one
that's still with us today and that
is the anti vaccination movement.
Vaccination became one of the contested
debates of 19th medicine in Britain and
anti vaccination league was founded
and became a major political influence.
There were various sources of opposition.
There was the appear call
observation of failure, as I've said,
when people who had been vaccinated
actually contracted smallpox,
there was the opposition of liberals and
Libertarians to what they regarded as
the excessive power of the state
and making vaccination compulsory.
And there was religious opposition.
People will consider it an an active in
piety to introduce material from animals
into a human body.
And there were sardonic posters featuring
people undergoing vaccination while
they sprouted horns or turned into counts.
But despite vaccination,
there was in Britain an act of 1840 that
provided for free infant vaccination.
And from that time,
the annual tall from smallpox began to
plummet despite the fact that the 19th
century provided conditions that were,
would have been favorable
to promoting the disease,
improved and speedy
transport with steam ships,
canals and the railroad crowding with a
population that was ever more immobile,
massive growth and
urbanization and large cities.
And those,
uh,
changes and advances were reproduced
across Europe and North America.
And there were technological improvements
as well. All of which leads me to,
uh,
the end of this morning,
which was to saying in 1959,
the World Health Organization undertook
the unprecedented step of launching a
global smallpox eradication
program by means of vaccination.
In 1977,
the final natural case occurred,
and in 1980,
smallpox was declared by the WHL
eradicated everywhere on the globe.
So vaccination then comes with this
extraordinary history of public health,
of combating a major
disease like smallpox,
and actually eradicating it.
And what we'll want to do as we
move through the course is to ask,
what are the conditions
that make vaccination and
appropriate tool for public
health?
When is it not appropriate?
Why are there such difficulties with
poliomyelitis as we're speaking today with
smallpox,
the beginning of a wave of
diseases to be eradicated this way,
one by one,
or was smallpox a an exception,
a special case?
We'll stay tuned and we'll deal with that.